there are three main things that people
have to develop skills traits beliefs
about the world in my view entrepreneurs
are limited by one of those three at any
given moment so if you have impeccable
character and you have great beliefs
about the world but you have no skills
you will only be able to provide value
to the level of your skill and once you
add a ton of skills to your tool belt
the sky's the limit the flip side you've
got tons of skills but you don't have
the character trait of focus you can't
stick with something for a long time it
doesn't matter how skilled you are you
won't be able to accomplish it because
you don't have the character trait to
get there